it's another month and that means
another free halo 5 update the new
update hammer storm is now available and
it includes a new map new weapons and
the community favourite game type
grifball the new map is called torque
and it's a symmetrical map that caters
to capture the flag and assault game
modes it sounds like pistol sniping has
also made a return in the latest update
the classic halo combat evolved sidearm
can now be used in forge mode and war
zone if you were hoping for something
with a bit more heft the new update also
brings back the gravity hammer the
hammer can be picked up in forge arena
and war zone 343 also teased halo 5s
upcoming content updates that will run
through spring and summer the next
update is called ghosts of Meridian and
it will be followed by memories of reach
and hog wild the final update teased is
titled warzone firefight which will
resurrect halos PvE mode firefight for a
full list of all the new items and
gameplay tweaks in the latest update
check out the post on Halo Waypoint and
for more halo news stay tuned to
gamespot com